[Music]
lyndon henderson that kind of rhymes i
like that i'm gonna i'm gonna sing this
song all day what's up lin
hi doctor john how are you
i'm good how are you outstanding
outstanding what's up
hey so i have a question for you
um i'm a teacher and i have several like
teacher assistants who work for me oh
god bless you um
oh my gosh wow
what do you what grade do you teach
um i'm actually a special education
teacher i work with students with uh
behavior challenges and trauma
backgrounds
quadruple
i'm making all of the i don't have a lot
of religious hand signs i don't know a
lot of them but i'm making all the ones
that i know um at you good for you good
gosh so you are
someone who works with children with
behavior challenges and
childhood trauma and you decided you
know what else would be fun just to
bring in some student teachers
well they're not student teachers
they're teacher assistants like they are
um they're there to do a full-time job
okay excellent yeah yeah all right
that's not quite and generally
thanks although i have had student
teachers too
teaching assistants are actually awesome
i've got a couple of friends who are
teaching assistants they're they're
great they're incredible yeah all right
so i keep interrupting you go ahead
so i generally have between five and
seven um each year right now i only have
three who are a little short staffed
however
i have one
right now she's kind of um she's
throwing me for a loop she
she kind of just says off color things
which i've stopped in front of the kids
but she'll say things like um
well does anybody have some bleach water
i can drink or i guess i'll just go take
a bubble bath with a toaster tonight or
i just think i'm gonna go kill myself so
um she stopped saying those in front of
the kids because i
like i stopped that but she said that in
front of a couple teachers recently so
um
then they came and talked to me so then
we had a meeting with my principal we
kind of talked about professional
language um you know and you know what
it looks like to be professional she's
21 she is young um but
she just says you know her her comeback
is this is just how i cope this is how i
cope with life my question to you is
is that really like is that a coping
skill should i be more concerned um i
just like i mean she's just putting me a
little bit on edge because of what i do
for a living and the kids i work with
absolutely
so number one
you're good for you thanks for
i'm glad you had like i'm i'm thinking
in my head yeah this needs to be
escalated have a professional
conversation here
um
the
i i don't buy that for a second this is
how i cope
not even for eight seconds not for half
of one second that's nonsense there's
professional behavior
and then there are
cries for help
and so
you my first thought would be yeah bring
her to your office maybe with the school
counselor and you went with the
principal awesome and have a very direct
conversation
and
here's how i handle this when somebody
makes let me back up i used to make that
joke too a lot
and i thought it was so egregious and
silly that it was me just being off
color right just being like oh man i
might as well just go like whatever i
can't even do it as a joke anymore
because i've been around it so much
um but when i was 21 i did it all the
time i thought it was funny and it
wasn't and it took a couple of people
intervening it may have been one of my
lead high school teachers that was like
dude that's not funny um or it may have
been me just dealing with that situation
and realizing this isn't funny but
all to say is i've been there it's not a
coping mechanism you when somebody says
i might as well go drink bleach water
here's what i do or i'm gonna go ahead
and just take a bath a toaster in it or
something like that
i call in the
how do you say it cavalry is that right
the cavalry
um i would sit somebody down take him
directly out in the hallway and say i
need to know right now are you going to
hurt yourself
and let them know i don't play around
with this stuff and i would have a card
that says here's resources
if you are feeling like hurting yourself
i want you to call somebody
and if i hear this again i'm going to
call 9-1-1
okay i'm going to ring every bell i have
because you keep telling me that you're
going to kill yourself
and you all had the professional
conversation i think next is time for a
write-up this is not this is not funny
okay in a context with trump traumatized
children i'm telling you as your
supervisor i don't think this is funny
and here's the thing let's take suicide
out of the conversation it could just be
fart jokes
or like butt crack jokes i think those
are hilarious i've been told probably
not in this meeting don't do that you
know what i mean and so i can i didn't
have a choice to make
am i going to keep this job or not
that makes sense it seems so simple yeah
to me
you are brilliant and you're empathetic
and to do the work you have to do you
have to have really firm boundaries
where is this getting sideways with you
there's a part of you that feels
suddenly on edge where is that
well i guess so
do you think she might be serious
well i have asked her point blank and
then she'll be like no
[Music]
i
i just yeah i just i i'm always very
careful like to be very direct with her
when when this has come up both times
but then i just like i just because of
what i do and because of the position
i'm in i mean i'm i'm taking care of
other people's kids like i just want to
be very
sure that um you know the people that
are in my room are you know that they
can do their job that they absolutely
are absolutely
you know they're clear-headed because we
get in some very um unique precarious
positions you know things really get
moving in my room sometimes so so you
have to make sure that people are i
handle those like i've been a classroom
i've been hit in the face before by a
high school student i mean i've been in
it yes
i handle those things
through off-color humor
through laughing through
we always like i've shown up to crisis
scenes and we're laughing sword and i
remember one time i was being at a scene
with a some folks and we were dealing
with some of the most bananas situation
you can imagine
and i was laughing so hard like my body
just
clicked over and i don't i to this day
don't know what happened but i was
laughing so hard i remember thinking if
somebody sees this on video we're gonna
we're getting um we're gonna be
institutionalized like this why are we
laughing so people handle that stuff
differently
but you also have to have enough body
and
social awareness to not do that in front
of a grieving mother or in front of a
hurt child you know what i mean
and so
i it sounds like a maturity issue with
me
if you think they're playing and hey you
don't play with suicide period but if
you think they're she's just playing and
this is how she's dealing with some of
the trauma she's seeing
yeah i mean it's time for a write-up
this doesn't happen again not not in my
classroom if you've got friends or
whatever but you're not gonna do that
and if you're gonna hurt yourself okay
here's one important thing i want to
make sure i hand her a document whether
it's a small laminated thing the school
counselor may have something here are
resources
that for for you to call if you need
help or care and i'm sure that with the
school district there are uh
what do you call them um
esa i mean there's people that you can
go out and reach out to me for
counselors things like that but um right
and if it's uh even remotely serious i
call 9-1-1
we're going to draw all the sirens get
everybody in here and you're gonna have
to sit down and look at a professional
and do a um do an assessment because i'm
not trained to do that
do you feel comfortable doing that
oh yeah yeah i can do that
all right
you're awesome
well thank you and tell her to call me i
would love to talk to somebody
who like
i'd love to talk to her that's such a
fascinating excuse i can't imagine
wrapping that excuse up this is just how
i cope you all just deal
seems strange
is there something else here i feel like
i'm missing something
no i i know i just she definitely has
a wrecked home life there's definitely
stuff there um
so i i do i think that she i think she
needs professional help she's 21. i mean
i feel like in some ways my hands are
tied i've you know i've given her
direction to go see a counselor but i
can't force her that's right you know
like i just there's like i guess when
you said like i seems like i'm kind of
stuck i feel like i'm stuck because i
feel like in one sense we are her safe
place like she comes to work because she
feels accepted
and loved here and yet i know i also
have to be this is my job and i have a
professional night to keep these kids
safe and so i just want to make sure i'm
walking that line oh gosh okay can i say
this this is real important
okay
counselors
i'll even go with doctors
teachers
who
use clients
students patients
to prop themselves up
do not need to be in those situations
and
i've worked with people closely in
in
with what you just described
which is this is their safe place
she her heart is filled up because she's
got a group of students who love her and
will lean on her and she can be the kind
of the funny one and the young one and
the jokes one and oh come on guys you
know what i mean
but she's using those kids to prop
herself up
and that is dangerous
that's how people say things and and get
involved in things and do things that
otherwise hurt kids and by the way kids
can feel that when they feel like their
job is to make sure the person that is
interacting with him needs to be okay
um kids can absorb that and so if you
get any sense that
she quote unquote needs these kids
not loves them and is engaged in working
with him
but needs these kids
needs this job to be okay
psychologically
that's a that's a that's a rough place
to put those kids in
okay does that make sense it does okay
and i know that it's really hard you
said it best you can direct her to
to care you can direct her where to go
to resources
and she's a 21 year old adult and she's
got to make that choice
oh i hope she makes that choice
and you can't fix her home life and you
can't save her
you can give her options and say i love
you and as far as i'm concerned i'm
going to call in the authorities every
time i love you this may not be the
place for you to work because you need
to get well before we put you in front
of a room full of
children with
challenges with any sort of child but
especially children with challenges
who need centered connected
firm-footed adults in their life
because those kids got to anchor into
something
thank you so so much lynn i'm so
grateful for you i know this is a hard
situation thank you for being who you
are and for doing what you do